I got just on the plane yes I had on
sweats and then I put my Tyra Banks
always looking gorgeous and glam no
matter where she gets ready let's luck
Oh how's the CB how's the CB thank you
the entrepreneur is hard at work on her
latest project model land yes Tyra is
creating a theme park what was this
coming together and like I just spent
last week at Dollywood so I'm all about
this type of thing like what is this
gonna be I'm it's gonna be great model
and it's gonna be insane it's going to
be bananas what it is is it's about you
coming and joining the uprising that we
are tired of this one defined narrow
Beauty and everybody that comes to
modeling is joining the uprising to take
down the people that say we are not good
enough okay well there be a roller
coaster that goes upside down maybe in
2040 no doubt Tyra is gonna need a lot
of engineers and scientists to bring her
creative vision to life she was in the
presence of many of them Sunday night at
the breakthrough prize ceremony which is
also known as the Oscars of science what
does it feel like to be here to
celebrate all these awesome people today
in a way that maybe they don't get
celebrated normally that's exactly why
I'm here I'm so used to doing carpets
like this and interviews like this for
people that are in front of the camera
you know lights camera action but none
of us would be here without these people
that are sustaining life and so it's
it's pretty amazing but you and your
brand
you've always sort of been someone
that's like okay beauty is one thing but
brains is a whole other thing
so you actually really do fit in here
why is that been so important to you to
sort of stand behind that it's been
extremely important for me I feel like
yeah beauty is beauty it's a shell I'm
all about expanding the definition of
beauty and making more people look and
feel more beautiful however it's all
about booty - okay not one body type and
brains still got beauty beauty and
brains those three and that's like the
triple threat
[Music]